well we talked about it in one video and
it looks like it could be true Marvel
Studios might be making the Silver
Surfer in the MCU a female and I know
that this could make a lot of people mad
however I don't think everything is as
it seems right now and I do believe that
Marvel Studios has a very specific plan
one that's actually Marvel accurate not
just for the MCU but also accurate from
Marvel Comics I believe I know what
their plan is at least I hope so because
of course they have been guilty of
gender swapping and race swapping
characters in the MCU from the comics
and honestly yes Disney does like to do
this sometimes just for the sake of
doing it but I don't think that's what's
going on here with this decision to make
the Silver Surfer a female now if you're
not aware several insiders have already
stated that they have heard that Marvel
Studios plans for the Silver Surfer are
indeed to make her a female whereas the
most widely known and most popular
Silver Surf Surfer iteration is norin
rad a male there is a version of the
Silver Surfer who is a female Juno I'll
explain her story in this video and also
explain what I believe is actually quite
a good decision by Marvel Studios to
have her in this film instead of norin
rad if that is indeed the route they go
down and if what I believe to be true is
true but I look forward to hearing what
you all think about this at the end of
the video also if you're new be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
down below then you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month so
according to Insider Daniel rpk Ana
Taylor Joy is reportedly being I to play
a villain in the Fantastic 4 right now
it's widely believed that she is going
to be playing a female version of the
Silver Surfer from what we've heard the
villains of the movie are going to be
galatis and one or maybe two Harolds we
also heard recently that the Silver
Surfer is going to be a female in the
very first Fantastic 4 movie so these
two reports line up very well with each
other so this news means that Anya
Taylor Joy could be the new Silver
Surfer of the MCU however I think this
could be very temporary not her being
considered for the role but if she is
cast as the Silver Surfer appears in the
movie I think it might just be for one
movie and we'll have a new Silver Surfer
moving forward after the first Fantastic
4 film don't worry I will explain
everything in detail so of course the
casting news about the Fantastic 4 has
been going crazy for a while now it does
look like we are getting an official
casting announcement from Marvel Studios
relatively soon the director Matt
shakman said it should happen pretty
quickly after the strikes basically what
that means is they have the actors in
mind that they want to play now that the
strikes are over they can offer official
contracts to them and the actress can
sign so that's why we've been getting
all of this news lately like Pedro
Pascal has signed on to play Mr
Fantastic of the Fantastic 4 and based
off of what we know right now Vanessa
Kirby is still our Invisible Woman This
has not been confirmed yet by any major
Outlet like some did for Pedro Pascal
but all of the Insiders are saying that
is what they've heard she has been
offered a contract and from what they
know she's accepted it but the Silver
Surfer news is just that it is new these
are new reports that we're hearing about
the Silver Surfer being in the Fantastic
4 film and her being gender swapped to
be female now we've heard about Galactus
and we've known about Galactus being the
villain of the Fantastic 4 for a pretty
long time now however earlier reports
weren't that sure if the Silver Surfer
was going to show up as one of the
Heralds of galatis in this movie we knew
Heralds were going to be in it just not
sure about the Silver Surfer plus we had
been hearing talks about the Silver
Surfer getting his own special
presentation on Disney plus
unfortunately we haven't really heard
anything about that for a while now but
what we have heard is that the Silver
Surfer will be a woman and she will
indeed be one of of the villains and
Heralds of galatis in the Fantastic 4
film now here is where I think Marvel
studios's heads are at right now here's
what I think they are planning if this
news ends up being true I believe they
will introduce Juno who is the female
version of the Silver Surfer in Marvel
Comics here's the thing about Juno she
exists in an alternate reality in the
Multiverse she's not just a character
who comes in and takes on the title or
mantle of the Silver Surfer in the main
Universe in Marvel Comics or in the the
MCU so I don't think Marvel Studios is
simply taking the Silver Surfer the main
Silver Surfer that will be a part of the
MCU for years to come and saying hey
let's make this character a female let's
have a woman play her I don't think
that's what they're doing I think they
are specifically choosing a female
Silver Surfer for this specific
Fantastic 4 film because we've heard a
little bit about this film and what to
kind of expect from its plot and what
we've heard from a couple of different
insiders is that the fantastic four film
might be set in a different Universe an
alternate reality just like in the
comics Juno is an alternate reality
alternate universe version of the Silver
Surfer that could be what we're getting
and it's kind of a good idea based on
what we know is going to happen in the
Fantastic 4 film and the future is still
open for the actual nor and rad the male
character to enter the MCU in the future
and stay for a very long time I'll
explain exactly what I mean but first
big thank you to Highland titles for
sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers got
something truly extraordinary for our
Noble listeners imagine that you yes you
can become a lord or lady for just $30
buying a plot of land from Highland
ties.com will allow you to make use of a
Scottish tradition in which land owners
are given a courtesy title with more
than 15,000 five-star reviews the
Highland titles gift pack is an
incredibly popular gift and the Highland
titles app available from the app and
play stores is a new addition that
allows you to explore a 3D replica of
the land choose the location of your
plot and decorate it using augmented
reality embrace the Majesty as every
purchase helps to conserve the awe
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can sore into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ties.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland ties.com and use code Cosmic so
most people are aware of norin Rad's
Story how he became the Silver Surfer
norin rad lived on the planet Zen La
then Galactus came to devour his Planet
norn rad convinced a group of scientists
to let him fly out in a spaceship to
greet Galactus in which when he did he
offered to be his Herald and seek out
new worlds for him to devour in exchange
of letting his Planet live Galactus
agreed then he turned him into the
Silver Surfer making his skin silver and
giving him Cosmic powers and this was
patterned after an adolescent fan FY
plucked from noren's actual memories
that he had Juno's story is kind of the
same but slightly different she was on
Earth 8 to9 she was the granddaughter of
Hercules who was just introduced in the
MCU but she offered herself to become
galactus's new Herald to save the
androma Galaxy and Galactus accepted her
offer and the same thing happened to her
she was turned into the Silver Surfer so
here's why Marvel Studios plans for the
Fantastic 4 in the MCU the first film
that is could be the best of both worlds
for us giving us a female Sil Surfer now
Juno and then nor and rad later from
what we know about the movie it's going
to actually end with galatis winning the
Fantastic Four are supposedly going to
be the only superheroes in their
Universe no other Heroes no Avengers
nothing like that they're supposed to be
super famous because they are the only
superheroes we don't know everything but
from what it sounds like Galactus is
going to show up with his heral Juno and
for whatever reason the Fantastic 4
cannot defeat them from there it's said
that the TVA is going to show up and
save them bringing them into a
completely different Universe where they
have a lot of other Heroes that they
saved from dying universes because
remember at this point will be pretty
close to Secret Wars and the Multiverse
is going to start collapsing and falling
apart so what I'm assuming is they're
only going to save the Fantastic for
team it wouldn't really make sense for
them to save galatis and his Herald so
then they'll be brought into a different
Universe they'll fight an Avengers
Secret Wars and then they'll end up in a
new universe or a restored Universe
after the fact and then the fantastic
will be a part of the main Universe
whatever that is after Secret Wars then
from there in this new universe Galactus
could become a threat again and the
Silver Surfer could be nor and rad in
our main Universe after Secret Wars if
this is what Marvel Studios is planning
then I am all for it because it gives us
a Galactus and a Silver Surfer in the
Fantastic 4 movie but it also enables
them to appear in the future so not just
a oneandone character because let's face
it Galactus and the Silver Surfer are
really iconic characters characters two
of the most popular characters in Marvel
history it would be such a shame if they
simply introduced them in one movie and
that was it kind of like and I hate to
say it Marvel Studios with Ultron so I
hope fingers crossed that this is indeed
Marvel's plan they'll introduce a female
Silver Surfer because it's going to be
an alternate universe so we'll have an
alternate version of the Silver Surfer
then after Secret Wars and the main
Universe moving forward they'll
introduce the main Silver Surfer moving
forward norin rad I really hope this is
the case but hey go ahead and let me
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below do you think
this is what they're doing or not please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest Fantastic 4 and Marvel
news you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof